Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how this new AI can
create entire virtual worlds out of thin air,
and to do all that, we don’t even need to
be a professional artist. This can do so
much! But how much exactly? Well, let’s give
it a hard time and see what it can do through
4 really cool examples, and then, it gets
even better, I’ll tell you in a moment why!
One, as you see here, it can generate a
great variety of different object types,
cars, animals, chairs, you name it. And,
would you look at that! I am very happy,
because I am already seeing two really nice
features here. Do you see them too? One is
that these are textured objects, most previous
techniques just give us the geometry, with this
one, we get nicely textured objects, that is super
nice, but, look! These are also regular 3D meshes,
which means a data structure that can be used
by most 3D modeling systems right away as it is.
That is not true for all previous techniques,
for instance, some of them even give us point
clouds instead. And textures aside, if you
compare the quality of the results to these
previous methods, there is a night and day
difference. This is so much better. So cool!
Now, two, the fact that it can generate a
great variety of objects is all well and good,
but what if we kind of like this object, find it
to be almost exactly what we like, but we would
wish to change it a little. Can we do that?
Well, that’s tough. For that, we would need
a latent space interpolation technique that is
akin to this earlier font generation method,
or like this material generator from our
earlier paper where we can walk around on
this 2D plane and fine-tune a material that we
already like. Doing the same with these objects
would be fantastic, but let’s not kid ourselves.
That is significantly harder in this context. So,
can it do it? And the answer is, look at that!
Yes it can! And what is even more impressive
is that nearly all of the intermediate results
make sense. That is the hardest part. Loving it!
And, if it stopped there, that would
already be amazing, but it doesn’t stop
there. There is so much more! Three, get
this, it even understands the difference
between geometry and texture. This means
that whenever we modify the geometry,
the lamps still have the appropriate texture
and colors, it also understands that as we
create an SUV from a smaller car, the doors
and windows now have different placements.
That is an excellent showcase of an AI technique
that actually understands what it is generating.
And now, here comes my favorite, they also
promise text-guided shape generation. Does
this ring a bell? Oh yes, we can prompt this
technique like we can prompt a text to image AI
like DALL-E 2. That would be amazing, but, have a
look. This is a previous technique trying to give
different animals tiger stripes, or actually, I am
not even sure what this is trying to do, or, make
these dogs a bit fluffier. Those are noble goals,
but unfortunately, this previous technique could
not pull this off. Not even close. And now, hold
on to your papers and let’s have a look at the new
technique’s results. Oh my goodness! There is no
contest here. Tiger stripes, fluffy dogs, you name
it. With this new method, we can create a tiger
or a panda out of any other animal, or ask for a
brick house, or burn it down by just writing these
two words and pressing enter. This is incredible
- we just write the text, the AI does all the hard
work, and we take credit for it. How cool is that?
And wait a second, we noted that this was the
best of what a previous method could do. How
long ago is this paper from? And this is
where I fell off the chair when reading
this new paper. This previous method is
not even a year old. It was published
approximately 11 months ago. And this kind
of progress in just a year? I am stunned.
And wait, I promised to tell you how it gets even
better. Well, it does all these amazing things,
and not only that, but normally,
with previous handcrafted techniques,
if we wanted to do these 4 things, we would have
needed 4 different algorithms for that. Years ago,
if we wanted to conquer Chess and Starcraft and
Dota 2, these are three different applications,
and thus, need 3 different handcrafted
algorithms to solve. However, this is
not the case here. Because this new technique
can do all of them at the same time. This is
not 4 tasks, and 4 techniques, this is just one
technique. That is super important. Why? Well,
there are many definitions for artificial
intelligence, but most of them contain
some sort or generality. A good AI technique
should be able to learn from a large dataset,
and obtain general knowledge from it. And
this is an excellent testament of that.
And, just imagine what this technique will be able
to do just a couple more papers down
the line. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!